[Music]
all right Joe Biden's weakness on the
world stage now is making America less
safe now Iran they issued a warning on
Thursday that a proposed usback task
force to protect ships in the Red Sea
would qu cause quote an extraordinary
problems in the region now the latest
threat comes after the US Destroyer had
to shoot down yet another hooti drone
over the Red Sea yesterday and again we
ask a simple question is Joe Biden ever
ever going to forcefully respond to
unprovoked attack like attacks like
these now given his disastrous track
record I don't think I'd hold my breath
anyway meanwhile in the administration's
latest show of wavering support for
Israel according to axos all national
security advisor Jake Sullivan is now
telling Israeli Prime Minister BB
Netanyahu that the quote high-intensity
phase of the Gaza War needs to end
within weeks however the Biden
Administration they are pushing back on
the report saying Sullivan did not give
a timeline and yet another report saying
vice president kamla Harris is pushing
the White House to be more sympathetic
to the Palestinians here with reaction
2024 presidential candidate Nikki Haley
you know maybe I'm oldfashioned um uh
Governor Ambassador but I will tell you
if you're going to be involved in any
conflict or any War you should have one
aim I will quote Winston Churchill
victory victory at all costs against a
monstrous tyranny wouldn't that fit here
why would Joe Biden be lecturing Israel
on how to fight and win their War for
them it's a war of
survival Sean this is why none of our
enemies fear us is because they see
exactly what Biden does he did this with
Ukraine now he's doing it with Israel
either you're a friend or you're not and
why are you taking the side of Hamas as
opposed to Israel if you say you're
going to be with Israel and support
Israel then do that but but you don't
start drawing conditions on what they
can and can't do this was a country that
fell to her knees with the worst attack
since the Holocaust and now they're
trying to eliminate Hamas the ones that
did this which by the way should be
personal for America because 33
Americans were butchered on that day
we've got American hostages let them
finish the job let them finish Hamas
once and for all stop telling them what
they can and can't do and stop worrying
about whether
and and the people of Gaza are okay and
start worrying about what are we really
going to do to protect the security of
Israel which by the way protects the
security of America all right maybe it's
me but I would say if Israel wants to
have full Victory they need to prevent
Gaza from ever again being a launching
pad for Rockets into their neighboring
cities uh I think V victory has to be
defined by ending that network of Terror
tunnels victory has to be defined by by
preventing Lebanon and Hezbollah from
firing missiles using Lebanon as a
launching pad into Israel firing rockets
and missiles and I would also say if
they want full Victory somebody's going
to have to at some point deal with Iran
the way I would deal with Iran nobody's
asking my opinion I would take out every
Refinery they have that would cut back
on their money supply and if possible
somebody at some point they better take
out those nuclear sites before Iran
married with their sick ideology
whereever to get a nuclear weapon would
you agree with
that Sean I mean you have to look at the
fact that Iran decided years ago and
they've been very good at it at using
their proxies rather than doing things
themselves there would be no houthis
without Iran there would not be Hamas
without Iran without Iran there would
not be Hezbollah without Iran so they're
using their proxies to do their dirty
work but they're if we really want to do
something why doesn't Joe Biden go back
and put the sanctions down on a Iran
that were already there why are you
letting billions of dollars flow to Iran
from China who's importing all of their
oil why are you continuing to talk about
an Iran deal when all that does is show
weakness and why not go after those in
Syria and Iraq that continue to hit our
military men and women hit their
infrastructure in Syria and Iraq give
them one big punch and they will step
back but right now they don't fear us
and that all started with the debacle in
Afghanistan it went on with Ukraine I
mean you see what happened there I mean
first of all the fact that Hamas invaded
Israel on Putin's birthday that was a
gift to Putin there's a reason he is the
happiest man in the world because what
happened basically us took us and the
West took their eyes off of Ukraine and
put their eyes on Israel and so now
Putin's hoping this is the moment he can
take Ukraine and go into Poland and the
baltics and then we are at War this is
about preventing war and Biden is
failing on the job miserably and making
the world less safe I would like to see
America and I know you were the UN
Ambassador um I don't trust these
globalist organizations anymore uh
historically they have been
anti-American and they have been
anti-semitic I talk to you about this I
don't trust the World Health
Organization uh they were basically
propagandist for China uh on the issue
of covid I don't trust the wef I don't
trust the Paris Accords that we were
part of
um and I feel like anytime we get
involved in these globalist
organizations it ends up badly for the
us and we end up paying billions and
billions and of dollars that we can't
afford does this need to stop should
America now Retreat from some of these
globalist
organizations yes and we need to go what
and show exactly what we mean when we do
that it's the reason that we got out of
the Paris climate agreement when I was
at the UN it's the reason we got out of
the Human Rights Council it's the reason
we stopped any taxpayer dollars going to
the Palestinian refugee organization we
absolutely should get out of the World
Health Organization and anything that
the UN is doing look at how they failed
at looking at the human rights abuses of
what has happened to the women on
October 7th they're nowhere to be found
they continue to show themselves to be a
farce we should defund the UN as much as
possible and let them know that until
they start to become legitimate we're
not going to sit there and put any more
money into it because right now what's
happening is China's winning with these
organizations Russia's winning with
these organizations and no one is
putting a stop to what they're doing
it's because they smell weakness it's
because they smell blood America has
lost its footing we can get it back we
can get it back but it comes with
American strength American strength
always prevents Wars and gets the world
to be more at peace we've got to go back
to that last question Governor D santis
was on this program last night tonight
he wants to debate you one-on-one right
here on this program what would your
answer be
up well I've debated him four times I
love debates I have no issue with that
but quite honestly Sean the person I
want to debate is Donald Trump if you
can get him on your show that's who I
want to debate that's who we're looking
at that's who's you know we're second
place in Iowa second place in New
Hampshire second place in South Carolina
Donald Trump's the one we're looking in
the windshield and that's the one that I
think needs to get up on the debate
stage I think you'd be great at it I
welcome you to try and put get that
together um but that's our Focus right
now is getting Donald Trump on a debate
stage any debate stage that that does
not have Chris Christie on it is one
that I'll approve of I'll put it that
way uh anyway Nikki Haley thank you for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else